it is the Year 1200 and the world is
about to change in dramatic fashion
let's just give ourselves a little bit
of context of what the world looks like
the kings of Western Europe are caught
up in the Crusades in the year 1200 the
Third Crusade has just ended and is
mildly successful but Jerusalem is still
in control of the Muslims the Byzantine
Empire what's left of the true Roman
Empire is on the decline losing more and
more territory to the Turks in the
Middle East and Persia you have the
Golden Age of Islam the Abbasid
Caliphate is still around although it
has now been fragmented into many
different Muslim empires modern-day
North India Pakistan and Afghanistan is
under control of the grid Sultanate with
the rest of India being divided amongst
various Hindu kingdoms in the east in
other videos we study the Song Dynasty
which is one of the really high points
of Chinese civilization although they're
suspicious of their northern neighbors
but in the midst of all of this it ends
up being a nomadic people that we really
haven't talked a lot about in our survey
of world history that become the main
catalyst for change over the next
several hundred years and that is the
Mongols so let's move forward to the
year 1206 in the late 12th and early
13th centuries you have a leader by the
name of Tim mujin arise in Mongolia and
he's able to unite the various nomadic
tribes and declares in 1206 a Mongol
Empire you see here in this yellow color
he is eventually called
Gen geese or Genghis Khan the Great Khan
the great ruler or the universal ruler
now even though the Mongols were not a
focus point of world history up until
this point they did have several very
significant things going for them
this point in history as nomadic tribes
of herders they were excellent horsemen
and they were also excellent archers
capable of shooting an arrow in any
direction while riding a horse so as a
military they were incredibly nimble
they were incredibly fast they were
incredibly brutal but they were also
incredibly adaptable as they conquered
more and more people they learned from
them and by the time of Genghis Khan's
death in 1227 they had conquered much of
northern Asia and the Mongols will
continue on within half a century of
Genghis Khan's death they will have
conquered not just northern Asia when
they capture Baghdad many historians
consider this the end of the Islamic
Golden Age as much pressure the Western
Europeans were putting on the Turks
during the Crusades it was actually the
Mongol threat that was much more
significant before fragmenting it is the
largest contiguous Empire in world
history I use the word contiguous
because the British Empire actually
covers more land as you'll see a few
hundred years later but the Mongolian
Empire all of the land was connected it
was contiguous as you can see from this
drawing they began to fragment into
what's referred to as multiple Connie's
that become more and more independent in
the second half of the thirteenth
century as we get into the 14th century
we can see that is now fragmented into
multiple still very significant empires
in the East you have Kublai Khan's Wan
dynasty controlling modern-day Mongolia
and China re-emphasizing the importance
of Buddhism until they eventually get
reconquered by the Ming Dynasty in
Central Asia you have the chaga Tai
Khanate in Northwest Asia and Eastern
Europe getting as far as Poland you have
the Golden Horde and in Persia and the
Caucasus you have the ilkhanate which
you can view as a subordinate Connie but
is now independent deaconate
in the west eventually convert to Islam
super
important to understand because many of
the empires that we're about to study in
Asia and the Middle East have roots in
the Mongolian Empire and roots in what
Genji's khan started in 1206